il faut que nous comprenions que c'est
par une action continue que nous
réussirons à créer des emplois qui soit
sain et
durable bien entendu cela n'empêche pas
le gouvernement de mener une politique
spécifique de l'emploi 44 milliards de
francs sont à l'heure actuelle
consacrés à l'indemnisation du chômage
pour 22 milliards de
francs à la professionnelle pour 14
milliards de francs aux mesures en
faveur des jeunes pour 6 milliards de
francs et à des aide à l'emploi pour
plus de 2 milliards de francs voilà ce
que fait le gouvernement et je suis prêt
à accepter toute comparaison entre la
politique qui est menée par le
gouvernement et d'autres politiques qui
ont été menées en France ou qui sont
menés à l'étranger je suis prêt à
l'accepter accepter cette comparaison en
toute sérénité